welcome back to peers organization she's
the self-help author and Democratic
presidential candidate who once said she
would harness love to defeat Donald
Trump she believes the power of the Mind
may have prevented a hurricane hitting
the United States in 2019 and she once
wrote The Sickness doesn't exist in
diseases like cancer and AIDS and other
physical illnesses are physical
manifestations of a psychic scream now
some of that she's walked back with a
history of saying things that many May
deem quirky at best does Marianne
Williamson really believe she has a shot
of becoming the first female president
of the United States well let's find out
she joins me now Marion Elizabeth great
to have you on the program
thank you so much so I want to start
with some of those things that you've
said in the past I know you've walked
some of them back but when you run any
of them well you I think you did when
you talked about you don't take any of
it back
it's not about walking them back it's
about pointing out how disconnected they
are from the context in which any of
those things were said I never said that
the power of the Mind these are all
misrepresentations and
mischaracterizations of what I've said
if you say I have to walk them back it's
as though I'm supposed to admit that I
said something completely ridiculous
nothing that I said within the context
that I said it was ridiculous at all
that's all would you would you say you
regret any of those things that we
referenced not if you look at the
context in which they were spoken no I
you know no I shouldn't apologize for
the fact that there is now an
understanding of a mind-body connection
anybody in any kind of a
psychotherapeutic situation might say oh
I'm in such pain it feels like my body
is screaming listen I have osteoporosis
my mother died of diabetes my sister
died of breast cancer my father died of
colon cancer I have spent most of my
career being of service to people with
AIDS and other critical illnesses no one
needs to school me on the reality of
illnesses and it's and its ravages I am
not a woman who doesn't understand those
things you are a woman and if you were
to win you would become the first female
president of the United States and that
does beg the question the burning
question one that has tripped up so many
famous people in the world of politics
around the world has cost people their
jobs so let me ask you straightforwardly
what is a woman
what is a woman well a woman if you look
at it only biologically you know I wrote
a book called A Woman's Worth I am a
woman who was born into a woman's body I
think of myself as a woman but it's a
different it's it's a different world
today people can Define their sex their
sexuality binary non-binary however they
want I just know what I am as a woman so
I'm not going to get trapped into any of
that you know we live in a free society
and in a free Society people can
identify however they wish to identify
do whatever they do as long as it
doesn't hurt anyone else and I have no
problem when it does hurt for example
female
Sports people who are suddenly seeing
themselves come up against trans women
who might be six foot four inches tall
and a powering past them in swimming
pools that does do genuine harm what's
your view about that issue
that is a complicated subject absolutely
but there are ways through muscle mass
through hormones through Chemical
Testing there are ways to to determine
you can't think though as a female
candidate to be president you cannot
surely think it is remotely fair for
Trans athletes and I've got nothing
against trans people I've always
supported their rights to fairness and
equality I just feel that this is
completely unfair and trans athletes
should simply not be allowed to to
compete against biological females and
those situations once again they're
complicated they're not all the same
officials it is actually because there
are some situations where it may be what
you just said other situations where it
may not be you know it's important that
we protect the rights of the minority
it's also important that we protect
protect the rights of the majority so
those things should be determined
according to factors that are uh that
are agreed upon by the sports officials
and all of the people seeking to be part
of those races should be protected their
rights should be protected and honored
what would be the first thing you'd do
as president if you want
one of the first things I would do is
determine that there would be an audit
for the Pentagon every Sunday every cent
that we spend there I would cancel all
contracts where the United States
government has contracts with union
busting companies I would deschedule
marijuana from a schedule one drug I
would bring together a group to have a
very serious conversation about how we
were going to get to Universal Health
Care and I would also use the marching
rights that are part of the by Dole Act
of 1980 by which pharmaceutical
companies are told that if you developed
a drug with even one dollar of taxpayer
money which means most drugs in the
United States that the government has
the right to lower those prices I would
bring together a group of leaders who
were the experts on childhood everything
having to do with the neurophysiology of
children
neuropsychology the the needs of
children in terms of health in terms of
Education everything that it would take
to have the greatest experts on
childhood because I want to develop a
Department of Children and Youth I want
a massive transfer of resources into the
lives of children 10 years and younger
okay
I'm going to run out of all time but
okay that all sounds very laudable as a
as a and you rattle them off you've
obviously thought about it a lot which
is good what would you do for example as
commander-in-chief if China invaded
Taiwan
that's a very very difficult one that's
a very very difficult one and hopefully
hopefully if I'm the day I'm president
China will not have invaded Taiwan I
will certainly not poke the bear I would
certainly try to walk back any of this
almost Cold War type of conversation
that is happening too much between the
United States what if you were
commander-in-chief and they literally as
many people think is highly likely in
whoever is the next president in that
term of office if they did invade Taiwan
Joe Biden has said he would be there to
help would you
what did you say that Joe Biden has said
he said that he would help the Taiwanese
if that happened well there are
different ways there are different ways
to help the Taiwanese and I believe that
we're trying to help them right now and
one of the ways that we're also trying
to help the Taiwanese is is to build
better relationships with China so that
we can be more on a road towards healthy
collaboration which we will need not
only economically but in order to deal
with the climate crisis in the years
ahead so let's right now work on where
we are let's not poke the bear let's
take the temperature down let's think in
terms of of China not as an enemy but as
a collaborator hopefully someone that we
can compete with in a healthy way
well I say it was a great respect but
people will say that's very naive that
we've just you know if you did the
attitude with say Vladimir Putin that's
not going to stop him invading countries
and people look to America for better or
worse as the global policeman and if you
want to run the country you want to be
the boss you're going to face some very
tough decisions about what you do when
the bears actually go and do bad stuff
thank you Paris I understand what the
role of the commander-in-chief of the
United States is but there was nothing
naive at all about what I just said
about China and the last thing I'm not
naive about is Vladimir Putin Joe
bidener said he won't debate other
Democrat candidates in the primary
season many people think that's just
cowardly what's your view
of course he should debate us there are
three candidates for this nomination
there is not an enthusiasm in this
country as you were mentioning earlier
there is not an enthusiasm for a trump
Biden rematch the majority of people
have said that they wish the president
would not run again if the American
people hear his agenda for the next four
years and they are hear my agenda for
the next four years and the agenda of
anyone else who is running and they say
through their votes on a Democratic
primary yes I think Joe Biden is the
best candidate to win in 2024 and the
best leader for the next four years then
God bless him he should be the one but
the idea that the DNC and the Democratic
Elite establishment can just shoehorn
him into the nomination is undemocratic
you if you have a party which we do that
likes to think of itself as a champion
of democracy we should not be so wary of
democracy in our Earth it is important
that the president debate me I
completely agree
um I suspect he's quite afraid of
debating you actually
um
what do you make of this issue of the
Biden family and all this foreign money
from adversaries which appears to have
been pouring into their coffers
well you know it appears to be we don't
know yet the facts aren't all out this
is we have rules of due process in this
country and no one whether it's Donald
Trump or uh President Biden should be
above the law we'll see what happens but
no matter what happens this is certainly
a shadow on his candidacy and one more
factor for people to think about in
terms of a president whose approval
ratings are already very low so there's
Hunter Biden is not his father we don't
know we don't we don't know anything yet
um but yeah I mean this is not great
going into a presidential uh
presidential race all the more reason
why the President should be debating me
and anyone else who is running so that
we can present to the American people
who get lost in all this this is what is
so wrong you know as you were speaking
about earlier it's like a circus of smut
and a racehorse and and gossip we need
to think about the American people who
are lost in all this the American people
one in four of whom have medical debt 18
million of whom cannot afford to pay the
the pay in order to fulfill the
prescriptions that their doctors give
them half of our seniors live on less
than twenty five thousand dollars a year
we have a third of our workers who live
on less than fifteen dollars an hour and
cannot even pay the uh pay for a place
to live these are the people who are
looking at all of these institutions and
saying you're failing us you're not
doing anything for me and that's what I
want to talk about
U-turn in this country
should somebody who's just been found
guilty by a jury of sexually abusing a
woman
should that person be allowed to run for
president
everybody needs to vote for well right
now they can legally so every voter has
to choose for themselves but I'll tell
you something this is not about listen
people who are total Trump supporters
like the person that you had on earlier
she doesn't care they're not going to
care that's not what's going to lose for
the Democrats in 2024. the power of
trump is not what's going to lose for
the Democrats in 2024. what could lose
for us however is droves of people
staying home particularly young people
particularly young people who are not
going to go to war for a president who
approved the willow project and has
given more oil drilling permits than
even Trump did and who do not see in any
way regarding their health care
regarding their capacity to go to
college regarding these college loan
debts that are tackling them they don't
look at the Democratic party and feel
they have my back either no I think
that's what is dangerous for the
Democratic party in 2024 all the people
who might be staying home unless we
present them a genuine opportunity a
genuine alternative of economic reform
and a whole new face and obviously I
think that fate should be obviously you
think that face should be you and you
put your case very compellingly and it's
great to have you on Piers Morgan on
censor thank you very much thank you
getting very interesting that race in
America just on the Democrat side with
Robert F Kennedy Jr and now Marianne
Williamson both polling surprisingly
strongly against Joe Biden may not be a
given that he ends up being the
Democratic candidate that would be a
bombshell